the original idea for this project came
from our brilliant character designer on
the film Shannon Tyndall I've worked
with Shannon about 10 years ago on
Coraline the first film that we made at
the studio he was one of our key
character designers and even even at
that time going back to when we first
met each other I was really impressed by
his his eye for detail his design
sensibilities but he also had a really
fertile mind and so when he called me up
his little over five years ago and he
said he had a number of projects that he
wanted to pitch to the studio that he
thought might make decent films and and
there was one of them in particular that
got me really excited and that was the
idea that eventually became Kubo and the
two strings and the thing that excited
me about itwhat that really drew me to
it was it it really tapped into a number
of different things that I've loved
since I was a kid you know when I was
when I was a boy I devoured epic
fantasies I absolutely adored them
everything but CS Lewis and L frank baum
and Lewis Carroll
but above all j.r.r tolkien was at the
top of that heap and it really was a
gift for my mother when in fact when my
mom was pregnant with me and when she
was recovering in the hospital after I
was born she was reading Tolkien's Lord
of the Rings so in a very real way these
things have been a part of my life since
since the day I took my first breath it
was one of the first great gifts and my
mom has stood upon me and my dad for his
part he you know he gave me a very
different gift but one that was just as
important when I was around 8 years old
he let me tag along on one of his
business trips to Japan and I grew up in
Portland Oregon and from the moment I
set foot in Japan it really was like I'd
been transported to another world it was
just so beautiful and breathtaking and
almost otherworldly and the whole
experience was a revelation for me and
so this film is effectively the
convergence of those two things it's a
love of fantasy that I got for my mom I
love the transcendent art of Japan that
I got for my dad all bound together in a
film that's about the sustaining love of
family so it's a film inspired by family
about family as you guys now are using
stop-motion but also CGI and and and
computer-generated animation how do you
say okay this is going to be this or
that's going to be that and how much of
that shifts throughout production and
how do you keep your thumb on the budget
and the time and yeah how do you do what
you do it's a good question I think we
were as a studio not really ready for
this movie until now so
so we've been here for ten years all of
these incredible people have been here
you know all along and I think Travis
especially was looking for a really big
epic action adventure something we could
sink our teeth into and it wasn't until
maybe five years ago that we're ready to
do it and so what was there were a lot
of things that were really worrying some
about it it was a big outdoor action
adventure with this huge scale and of
course we shoot on you know tabletops
like desks inside a warehouse in the in
the dark so that was challenging there's
tons of water there's different kinds of
characters that we hadn't tackled before
but we have learned so much through the
different kinds of movies that we've
done before and every the whole group
you know of creative collaborators are
really here with us this whole time so
once we learn one thing okay we know
that we can put that into our library of
things that we know how to do and we can
tackle something new and so at that
point we were ready but terrified how do
we decide to shoot in the camera I think
we always want to shoot in camera as
much as we can
because it will look whole it'll look
like a movie to look you know more
beautiful and you know as you travel
through a movie like this where you've
got like 80 different locations maybe
you want to make sure that it looks
apart you know that the world looks
really whole at made of one hand and I
think we try to do everything in camera
and that which we cannot do in camera we
turn to our visual effects Department
our visual effects Department is like
these guys here with us at the very
beginning it's not something that we
decide to do at the end of the movie
like a post-production thing you know
afterthought they work and collaborate
with these guys with all of us from the
beginning and so we're more you know
easily able to tackle things and we also
do things really differently it's it's
not like it's not necessarily
traditional the way you might do it
movie so we have a few tricks up our
sleeves Georgia puppet fabrications
supervisor I'm assuming that means urine
you supervise all the manufacturing of
the puppets how do you even begin to
figure out what the materials are that
you're going to use it I mean it all
starts at the beginning of the film so
we have an amazing production designer
who is researching the look of the
entire movie and actually a lot of the
influence across the board of the movie
was taken from origami paper folding the
simple graphic lines of paper folding so
when it came down to us having to make
puppets out of origami we did the same
thing we went to another level of
research I had a team a small team of
people who had been making stop-motion
traditional puppets up until that point
but we had a lot of visual reference we
tackled all of the characters firstly in
traditional origami we had a woman that
came in and she did all of the maquette
in paper in origami and it was then our
job to work out how on earth we were
going to make this you know able to
withstand an animator touching it let
alone animating it for a year so we went
through material development and we also
sort of went through deconstructing
paper folding origami techniques to then
reconstruct them into a moveable
workable puppet so each of our origami
characters had metal armatures and
underneath the paper that it was a
combination of hard parts which were
covered in in the paper and I say paper
we couldn't use paper the first puppet
that we've sent out there with a little
bit of paper on just tore up instantly
so we actually ended up using Tyvek
which you know commonly in the building
trade and in the suits that people go
into laboratories in it looks like paper
but it has this amazing tear strength
you know you can't tear it
you also can't paint it very easily so
that was a bit of you know the thing
with puppet making the fun of it is you
have a problem put in front of you or
you know a creative challenge and that's
what it's all about how are we going to
figure this out and visual effects
helped us well but only to a small
degree you know a lot
what you're seeing out there it's
practical and it was a lot of the
animators informing us what they needed
to turn a flat piece of paper into a
three-dimensional origami character
fantastic and I assume that you must
have worked very closely with Deborah
because at the same time that you're
creating these puppets which seems like
too simple a word to be using sorry but
how do you begin to be a figure out not
only what these characters should look
like but whether the practicality of
that is going to work out there's a lot
of research done beginning on the
engineer and if the costumes as much as
the history of the character and the
history of the film the Japanese history
of the film that we looked into as well
but following on from what George said
about origami in forming a lot of the
characters we also use that as a jumping
off point for how the costumes were
going to work as the kimonos are mainly
flat wide shapes that are just wrapped
and tied to bodies and they're not
tailored which we've been used to making
they're used to being fitted to the
armature and how do we control all of
those folds so looking at origami just
as a jumping-off point but also looking
at EC Miyagi's designs who created
folded clothing that just is very
elegant over a body and follows the form
of a body using those as inspiration
it's how we were going to make those
graphic lines a language for the film
that travel between the characters so a
lot of our costumes now have their own
engineering underneath and they pretty
much have their own armatures at this
point especially in this film and
especially with the sisters character to
control those folks there's a lot of
engineering underneath that we've
developed over the course of time in our
costume making for like where we learn
learn one thing or trick because you
might want to call it on on one film and
one costume but we can reinterpret that
and use that in a different area on
others so it's a combination of those
things so there's several materials
under those costumes including Tyvek to
make the wrinkled surface they have
weighted linings made with tungsten the
nickel
to unglue this laser-cut to create the
gravity in the scale and the kind of
dimpled surface of old silk and then
armed armatures to control the flow of
the sleeves so Brian director of rapid
prototyping I love that title I don't
mean to make fun of it at all I thought
sure that there was a lot of thought
into coming up with that title so
explain first of all what that is and
how that interfaces with you know for
the further layman so basically what we
do it like for facial animation is we
are combining about a hundred-year-old
technique of replacement animation with
21st century 3d printing technology this
is something we started over a decade
ago on Coraline and we were the first
studio to ever try this crazy idea and
essentially what it is is instead of
hand sculpting different facial
expressions that an animator would then
be putting on a puppet in taking a frame
of film and then replacing that
expression with another hand sculpted
face we thought could we actually do
that in the computer probably one of the
best examples of replacement animation
before Coraline would have been Jack
Skellington in Nightmare Before
Christmas and he had about 800 facial
expressions for the entire film so our
original goal was hey we're gonna be
able to produce 800 faces pretty quick
using this 3d printer so back on
Coraline we were producing these faces
out of a plastic printer that then we
needed to go in and actually
individually hand paint every single
face so we were really pushing the
performance of these characters to
unseen areas but we were still really
having to dial back the sophistication
of how their paint jobs could look on
ParaNorman we started looking at
different types of 3d printing
technology which is started looking at
color 3d printed technology and we were
using that and have used that since
ParaNorman boxtrolls and we use that for
the human characters on Kubo but one of
the downsides to this powder color
printing that we were using it was
really hard to get fine feature detail
so when we were seeing the early on
character designs for kuba on the two
strings there were three characters in
particular that we're very
nerve-wracking for
so the monkey character with her fur
beetle with his you know hard facets on
his face and then the the moon Bea's
character at the end that serpent and it
was the first time in my career that I
we were at a crossroads that I either
had to go back to the director and say
hey our technology that we're using
isn't going to be able to complete your
vision or do we find a new way to do it
and the amazing thing about the last 10
years of like it and the rapid
prototyping process is not only had we
made a name for ourselves in the 3d
printing world Arches me in the
animation world we'd also made a pretty
name pretty good name for ourselves in
the 3d printing world we had an
opportunity to reach out to some of
these companies and say alright what do
you guys have in beta testing what do
you guys have in in machines that you
haven't released to the public yet is
there any way that we can actually tap
into that and see if that would help us
help deliver Travis's look for moon
beast and monkey and beetle and it was a
perfect scenario that where there was a
plastic 3d printer that was in the works
with a company called Stratasys we had
an opportunity to go to this 3d printing
company and say hey we love your
hardware but let us develop the software
let us be the ones who you know figure
out how we can take a face put paint on
it put three-dimensional paint on it and
then send it to one of these plastic
printers and it worked out really well
it was not without a lot of hard work
from a lot of very dedicated people that
we were basically trailblazing a
completely new way of producing plastic
color printed faces thank you very much
and thank you for saying